growing up in America Eddie lived the
American dream he achieved it all before
the age of thirty money cars women but
beneath the surface something didn't
feel right after achieving everything he
ever designed and he turned his back and
walked away from it all
and took his life in a whole new
direction let's take you on his journey
[Music]
Eddie was born in Buffalo New York to
parents who had emigrated from
Yugoslavia in the early 1970s
soon after Eddie's birth Eddie's father
decided to move to Chicago in search of
a better job my wife she was working I
was working I was working also nighttime
during that day you know on the weekend
usually his father comes late from that
kind of a work Kida was many times left
on his own was a son vacuum there and he
just filled it up with undesirable
friends and with undesirable things I
used to also took him to took him to
nightclub where I sing you know or you
know playing pool or during the daytime
when I fee that time I I don't know
really that how to race you know a child
we were more consumed with what normal
kids are consumed with just having a
good time
really just playing video games get him
out there on the streets and trying to
find something exciting an adrenaline
rush
growing up as a youth that had a lot of
say we had a lot of maybe confusion from
his early years Eddie always found
himself in trouble I wasn't the oldest
one of the bunch
but I was willing always to go a step
further I would sometimes go and defend
those who I thought to be really my
brothers and those who are close to me I
was the one to step up and make sure
that nobody was going to mess with my
brothers my friends I remember one time
and they catch him and the some other
his friend you know and he was a kind of
leader growing up he
I was I would say in his early years was
you know not too far from trouble but he
was always at the same time like a
concerning brother even though he was
involved in a lot of trouble he still
would make sure that you know me being
younger would not you know make those
same mistakes he made usually uh our
children formed by their 15th year you
know and once it's over harder to form
them later so during those 15 years
definitely there was a some lack of
proper upbringing you know us you know
children are like a garden you know you
water the garden you weed the garden you
know regularly and you miss it one week
and the garden is overtaken by the weeds
in a society that demanded both parents
to work the children would be the ones
most affected kids sometimes need more
attention if they don't get it at home
because the parents are busy working and
I know his parents were working a lot
and the zdenda he seems to me he needed
more time to be spent with him by his
parents Society taught Eddie to hone a
tough idea of manhood in elementary
school here we get in fights and you
have one group of kid kids fighting the
other group of kids so now you pick up
on this and that's that like street
mentality there was not knowing the
truth you know that was just believing
whatever he sees on TV or reading the
paper so it was my impression that's
that's how he saw the world you know in
Chicago I'm going to high school here
and you kind of feel like to prove your
strength and to be a ladies man to chase
women that's what most youth are talking
about that's what your love of statuses
he started having his problems
you know disobedience towards parents
gang activity fights it was
oh he was you know kind of disturbed
things were going out of the control you
know one fight here another fight there
trying to get this person's attention
school really was secondary it was
getting in class just to wait for the
bell to ring looking up at the time
oh man this is dragging on I hope this
will end soon so I can go and try to
hook up with this person or this crowd
cut class they are being bombarded by
all from all sides by things which are
immoral which are not good which are not
right on the TV on the internet on the
street newspapers there is so much bad
things and negativity that children
soaking up all those bad influences from
outside if the parent doesn't take time
to neutralize those that the children
don't have a way of learning what is
good what is bad they just take the easy
way and pick up whatever is thrown at
them as we learn birds of a feather
flock together so I was going around
along with the bad company I end up
getting what they call violated and they
put you up basically beat you up for
about you know a couple minutes and now
afterwards you're you're in
you've taken the beating and now you're
part of that clip that organization that
gang street gang the false sense of
Independence brainwashed
Eddie into living it rough and tough
gang life because hold the whole gang
thing the whole perception here is that
this is now my family and I felt like I
belonged to something I belong to this
group I belong to what I thought now was
my family which I had my family at home
who really cared about me and they
wanted what's what's best for me not
with these people they didn't care about
me misery loves company so I'm going
through life running away from home and
my mother she was going out of her mind
trying to find me and she drove up one
time into the school where we would hang
out and we're in this little courtyard
and she drives up this is the only place
where like the police would drive up but
she she drove up in here
we thought it was the police so now I'm
running from the police I'm running from
my parents I'm running here running
there I'm running everywhere but mainly
I'm running the wrong way gang life took
hold of any and forced him to travel a
negative and destructive path going from
one high school to the next I had to
leave that Lincoln Park because it was
an opposing gang so now if they find out
that I'm in this gang I mean that's the
whole school is associated with that
gang so I got to get out of that school
now I headed up getting transferred to
another school and I remember one time
when I was in the cafeteria and this
gangbanger of the opposite gain he came
and he threw down my gang sign so that
was the wrong thing to do and this is
something silly that you're ready to
kill the person over some stupid hang
gesture so he does that and I throw his
down he ends up pulling a knife I end up
pulling some mace I spray him and from
there all the different security guards
came at the school we get taken in to
the Disciplinary office and I'm expelled
finally I started figuring out that
these people didn't care about me
these gangbangers when you're sitting in
a jail cell and they catch you for some
kind of stupid crime some of these
people the police show you who the head
guys are and they've been arrested for
murder and all sorts of drug trafficking
these are the higher ones that are
basically pimping the young guys I said
I'm sitting in a jail cell and where are
they at nobody's coming to get me they
don't care about me and am I going to
end up with a mug shot like this and I'm
going to end up tomorrow killing
somebody
that's what it's heading to I mean that
you're going to get killed or I'm going
to kill somebody I'm going to end up in
jail destroy my life I have a good
family it's not worth it I ended up
going to Germany I thought this would be
a good break he disappeared you know he
took off we
went to different places in Chicago
where we thought he could be to find him
you know and we couldn't find him that
day my brother home from Germany
I assisted in Germany he call us he says
are you okay you let Eddie come over
here says no after spending time in
Germany Eddie realized his life was not
leading anywhere he finally returned to
Chicago only this time it was not to the
gangs big cash money was on Eddie's mind
how to make money so the direction I'm
getting caught is from movies from
actors the gangsters on the big screen
and I can relate to them everyone needs
a role model I thought that these the
rappers musicians the actors I'm
starting to see other people imitate
them so I feel you know what I can
portray this role quite well he
gradually worked his way up in the club
industry but money or not it still
brought trouble
one night policeman called me from the
station so you ready sir
father yes come on get him from the
station he's long time I went over there
and one also individual walking - from
from the station all of blood everything
you know I just went straight to it to
the desk and I was worried from what had
everything you do Eddie
and this officer he said he this officer
he says you ready Sade is did you see
the same picture the person just walk
out that's what you're sunburned fearing
that Eddie would get into deeper trouble
or worse his father convinced Eddie to
enlist with him in the US Army as a
civil interpreter in war-torn Bosnia
after I had been Bosnia working with the
military for some time I hooked up with
individual that I inspired to be like
when you watch some of the other good
fellows and you hear about Al Capone
this individual was the closest
resemblance to those people and I wanted
to be the top of that lifestyle and he
took great care of me he took me into
his home his many homes he showed me
around and said pick one and I saw the
lifestyle he had that country basically
it was his and he was someone who was
who you didn't wanna cross and he was
respected and I took to him and we were
very close Eddie returned to Chicago
from Bosnia with a new understanding of
the world and the same way he demanded
respect and loyalty this is something
that I demanded and if I didn't get then
I took and I put fear in people the same
way he was doing
influenced by his father's work in the
club industry
Eddie naturally began to seek out that
path we worked for from one of the
largest promoters in Chicago to any work
for him and I worked for him as well and
he was one of the guys one of the
enforcers he's to run around basically
just beat up people and I was really at
ease nature in his essence he was also a
ladies man and he brought in a lot of
the ladies at any given moment he could
have 78 women that are running around
the club looking for him while all of
this was happening Eddie who loved to
fight found a new form of release in
Brazilian Jujitsu I had boxed did some
boxing as a team and from there I had
tried different martial arts what I
really got fascinated with was the the
rationale and logic that hit me when I
saw Gracie Brazilian jiu-jitsu that
really went a hundred twenty one hundred
thirty pound guy around that he put me
it was called a submission arm lock and
I was so gassed and I was just about
back then working out because it was the
mentality or more you can benchpress the
more you know you were stronger and
physically able to push people around
and along with the boxing in that that
was a good combination but one jujitsu
that took hold this was something that
was really captivating and I just took
it to a whole nother level
you know there's 24 hours in the day but
it seemed like for 25 hours he was
training you know he was researching
training sparring this you know was in
love with it's jiu-jitsu you know
changing you know and I saw that it
wasn't always about booth strength that
there was a different way to approach it
and that was a totally different
experience the jujitsu I really start to
get involved in this because it
fascinated me was practical it it worked
I started to train in the jujitsu I
became the person who was out here the
instructor I became his top student but
jiu-jitsu wasn't enough to keep Eddie
away from the cooler lifestyle worldly
side someone were looking in you got it
made but there's something missing
inside one minute happy because there's
some pleasure that happens in my life
maybe I make some
money maybe I hook up with a certain
young lady really just again marking
time marking time I know a tease
presence was very significant in the
club everybody knew Eddie from the
outside people looking in said hey this
is the man when he was dating one of the
hottest girls in the city he decided to
get a get a Harley a chopper for 30 a
nice new Mercedes oh he's got the nice
car he's got the people who are flocking
to be around him they want to be on that
guest list you live in a dream but at
the end when you go through this cycle
again you just it's more corruption
you're around people who are just
cutthroat dirty business people liars
and I had learned better values for my
family as the cool became common Eddie
began to have a new sense of life we're
about six months into owning this
nightclub together we were probably
drinking six nights a week because we're
at the bar all the time so his training
went down about a women went up in Eddie
I think to this day may look at a god
way of kind of saying yeah you're having
fun but this isn't the way you're
supposed to be having fun all the power
he possessed still made him feel
helpless Eddie once beat up his best
friend who tried to steal Eddie's
girlfriend I don't think he felt any
better about himself his ego may have
felt better but his inner soul didn't
feel better than her soul was broken at
that moment he started to realize that
as strong as he is and as intimidating
as he is as an individual it really
didn't matter there was no peace the
overall entertainment around me
it had me hypnotized until situations
got heated like a big big fight we had
one of the guys a few of them really got
hurt one guy almost died and next thing
you know at 3 in the morning
the following night I'm getting knock on
the door the detectives are there and
I'm in the bullpen and in the county
jail and I'm praying earnestly
help me Oh God help me get me out of
here I don't want to be in jail
everything let me just get out kiss the
ground nobody wants to be there the
glamorous life Eddie had been living
felt shallow and empty there was no
peace of mind initially when we met it
said he seemed pretty perfect the
perfect life so all the women on the
cars a tough guy he can do anything he
wants to do runs around with his head up
but I think ought to know him it seemed
it seemed flawed there was things
missing his physical being was great
burrows ego but it left him empty
I kept it always real I said if I do
make a million I'll be the same guy I
might have a bigger house
maybe a nicer car but what then right
near the end there was just a void and I
started to look at some of the
celebrities lives I would go through
talking to some of these people and man
these people are more depressed than the
average Joe feeling loss Eddie started
searching for answers I sincerely wanted
to know what was my purpose in life it
didn't take long before Eddie was
reminded of death one time from coming
after an after party we had like maybe a
half a dozen of us stuck in an elevator
and I started to think about that moment
when we were stuck in elevator everybody
just cramped together and I was like wow
this is scary the incident shook Eddie
up this was the reality it was death and
it scared me because I knew that one day
I would be in the grave I would be in
the grave there is no an stiff but no
one can differ about this we can all
agree we are going to die and their
entertainment around us is just having
us not reflect over this I started to
read books I was like a sponge I just
kept taking in everything I took in it
just required effort it requires
sincerity wanting it first because if
you're not in the market if you're not
in the market then that's a different
story doesn't matter what comes to you
you're not going to be interested but I
was a in the market and I was sincere
and who better to tell me than the one
who created me this life is a test it's
short and you have to
be in a constant state of self
development to develop ourselves to be
the best human beings and I couldn't do
it on my own whims and desires so I
started to familiarize myself I started
to looking to different religions
because I wanted to see hold on what
about all the religions out there is a
lot of them so let me see now let me
have an open mind let me not non bias
and look into the different ways that
are claiming that they're the truth I
was in Brazil I was maybe a week from
coming home and I was talking to my
brother on the phone and then he asked
me a question in a slot like did you
read this book he wanted to make sure in
himself and inside his heart that that
was the truth the more I looked into it
the more I saw that Islam didn't promote
terrorism that Islam didn't oppress
women
that Islam was free from all these lies
that were just people backbiting the
same way they backbite out there against
individuals they were basically talking
out of ignorance not knowing and then I
felt compelled to talk with people when
my brother first started to learn Islam
he was so enthusiastic that he was
always been stubborn believing that his
way was the right way so I think by him
embracing that and understanding it and
by arming himself with all the knowledge
he can he became a very lethal
individual in his aspect of his religion
he did in the beginning in the
weight-room talking really loud and
things like that but we shortly found
out after people get it can be offended
people can have the wrong impression he
started to talk a lot more about
religion more barriers came up because I
don't think I was there where he was at
that moment in time there are so many
things he was struggling with he was
struggling with religion trying to
change his ways not drinking anymore
even after I learned I can't change
people's hearts at least I can share
this message and try to clear the
negative stereotypes
he backs he started talking behind his
back look at him he's starting to be a
good guy it was not as easy as Eddie
thought it would be I had been reading
more and just really thought that if I
just share this with the people that I
knew that they will come to the same
realization they would come
to the same conclusion you know that I
came to that this is indeed the truth
and the more I shared it with people it
would be funny because I get silly
arguments people just out of ignorance
some people they really wouldn't even
you know consider it
it was just thinking as they're
listening how I can refute this and
giving all the different proofs that I
had found and really you know for the
people that I was talking to it wasn't
really moving them whatsoever
I had an impact on me I was depressed
because these people that they loved to
listen to me talk about everything else
but when I started to talk about more
serious things hey guys look you know
what's the purpose of life people are
we're just stubbornly resistant and I
started looking at you like you're you
know from outer space and then I opened
up the Quran and in surah 2 verse 6 as I
rent from the beginning this is a book
where there is no doubt I realized that
I'm not in control of the hearts of the
people it was the one who is the crater
he's in control of the hearts
it wasn't about forcing people to change
I did my job I shared what I knew
there's new information now maybe God
Almighty will guide them at a different
time maybe at one point they'll realize
and go through some of the things that I
went through to get here Eddie's newly
acquired knowledge allowed him to see
life in a very different way now the
transition didn't happen overnight it's
not like now you find the truth and all
of a sudden you're just free from all
the different vices that you've had it
was a constant struggle I gave up
drinking right away I didn't I never
smoked but there was other vices that
took time for me to get rid of out of my
life when I was in these places it was
funny that I was giving people dollar I
was talking about something and it was
it was different to be in these in these
places and you see everybody's drunk
everybody's out of your mind
so he started less and less going to the
club you'll go to his parties but leave
like be there for an hour and leave
sometimes he would even show up and just
have me and someone else run it he kind
of like wanted to talk to people about
Islam but then he's
being a hypocrite as using the scene and
I think it force the more to get out of
it I didn't give up the prayer I would
hide somewhere to make it if I couldn't
make it in the club I would walk out of
the club and I would go and make it in
the car I did not give up that prayer
that was something that I feel it saved
me that he had stopped drinking at this
point me and Eddie used to drink a lot
at Eastern maybe more than me at that
point Eddie had quit drinking this over
a two three month time period he was
praying five times a day he was doing a
lot of reading a lot of studying on
Islam giving up the old lifestyle proved
to be a real struggle for Eddie but
determined as he was he quickly adapted
to the situation and he was able to
initially separate the two it was like a
switch he was able to come into
Butterfield 8 the night club we promoted
every Saturday and be a different person
maybe he would slip he would have a
drink
but then he would leave and it was like
he would he was shut the switch off so
now he would go and he was hurt he would
listen to a lot of documentaries he
would go read the Quran he would do how
he would pray it was dr. Jekyll mr. Hyde
and he was struggling with them but the
effort was there there was a conscious
effort to make that switch one setting
myself parted ways and we stopped doing
events together
that's where Eddie was able to separate
himself completely from the nightlife
the nightclub environment any felt
imprisoned by everything that was
surrounding him I have to get out of
this total you and the more I learned
and the more I implemented the easier it
became for me to start the transition to
leave a lot of the old friends I was to
get away from Chicago you need to get
out so I came down here visited I know
one night his last night here in Windsor
he was staying at the casino I think it
was a conscious effort on his part to
try to hit rock bottom he did things
things that he he pushed himself to the
to the ethical extremes that he could to
do things that to this day I think
played Layton in an integral role in
helping him evolve into the person he is
I remember seeing him the next day
before he left
and there was that emptiness in his eyes
it was a bigger emptiness that I think
I've ever really seen in his eyes
jiu-jitsu provided a way out for Eddie I
want to thank God also for jiu-jitsu
because you just to also help me to
spend more time doing something
constructive something that's fun and
and it helped me also the channel some
of my energy into something positive and
it's it's a struggle like life itself is
a struggle you to get better you have to
be more disciplined to achieve the
different belt levels you have to stay
with it you cannot give up working out
you cannot give up you see the benefits
at the end the martial arts have a very
strong history in etiquette and
mannerisms and things that that away a
culture a way to live that's outside of
fighting you know like having respect
being humble things like that so when we
before we were black belts and before we
were practicing Islam we were like the
complete opposite when you sign up for a
membership at a health club or at
jujitsu or anywhere there needs to be
some effort you get excited now you say
okay I need this what I need in my line
eed to lose weight now you get in there
and you sign up but after 2/3 class you
just lazy I mean you just don't want to
continue forward and now you only hinder
yourself now you're not going to
accomplish that great feeling of feeling
good looking good
being healthy it's going to require some
work it's the same thing here it's the
same thing with this way of life that
the Creator has laid down for all of us
to live it's a way to develop yourself
to be a better human being so you're
going to have to sacrifice you're going
to have to be disciplined there's some
things that you might have to give up
but if you are sincere and you earnestly
want it you're going to see that these
things weren't even good for me in the
first place I was talking about like
these are
but I'd look a little further out the
box you see this universe and everything
in it that design indicates a designer
we don't like that we can understand it
when people they go and they direct
what's supposed to be directed to the
Creator
they direct it to somewhere else I'll
give me $100 instead saying thank you
yeah I say thank you to someone else
[Music]
so it should be directed to the one
who's given you the eyes and ears your
life will give you that one pretty not
to His Messenger Saints idols icons to
him but of course if he triggering I
should say thinking things in my team
from this case to Islam to get oh no
when you see your brother give up on
your race with a hug and greet with
Salam Salam aleykum I'm a Muslim I came
from the streets to Islam to get home
now when you see your brother give a
bomb embrace with a hug angry with the
lies the land white eagle certain tricks
under the road I hope I never have to
look the cook crap the sauce over a bra
then I've controlled in my hand as a
hood rap along chicon always yeah I
would slash my first drum have my
adversary show round my bus with big
dreams when I push that my first time
love depended whenever and they will
release me a roll with these rational
marker then I end up back again was the
pray time please smile I'm wearing shoes
with a few graphs piece of my life will
be fool to police matter peacefully
moves on the street plan back into me
vanish a critique from and the roles are
in the prison how can he stand I found a
star like Africa digging for diamonds
show her in the Georgia Carter while I
ride it I should do what I like it'll of
fighting back to myself good to play
with my life spinning
[Music]
going to a high school to talk to some
faculty there Institute
I'm very excited to talk to the
non-muslims our brothers in the Manatee
we have three types of brothers you have
your blood brothers that you have those
brothers in humanity of when you hear
Islam and you hear something blowing up
you right away a tribute a lot of times
people tribute oh this is another Muslim
and now it's another event that's
attributed to its songs Islam peace
acquired by submitting your will to the
will of the creator
so you'll be getting God wanting some of
these DVDs which I have some of the
guests that come on scholars and come on
the show and we help tackle many of the
subjects that are the minds of the
people thank you for coming
Kevin Rogers living
last week you are
for sure
[Music]
bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
peace be unto you welcome to the deed
show which is a way of life we try to
put out there for everyone to see
helping you understand Islam and Muslims
uh when he started the Deen show it was
just an idea I was on my way I was about
to do the fifth pillar of Islam I
believe he was going to Hajj at the time
with my good friend so they wanted to
make sure that they did all the Hajj
requirements you know that they
fulfilled their Hajj and there was a lot
of different technical things that I had
to remember the ins and outs what I
couldn't do could do so they decided to
ask an Islamic scholar random questions
and tape it and we wanted to make it
more interactive where it wasn't just a
person giving a lecture it was someone
that we can interact with and make it
fine and we did that and from there it
turned out great and then it spun off to
another topic to another topic it
actually began with a regular cheap
camera four or five hundred dollar
camera and there was one angle and what
kind of zoom in the camera the the
tripod was shake or we all have in our
hands and I was trying to record and too
much wiggling and betty's concept was
you know he wanted to start showing
Islam and spread it to the non-muslims
he just fully wanted to have other
people experience what he's going
through did kind of was like what why
are we doing this I was gonna take you
serious and but Eddie wasn't going to
take no for an answer I said what Eddie
Eddie once you start something he goes
on our percent so he wanted to do it so
what he did he didn't wanna talk he took
a camera didn't matter what camera
camera it was and started recording
because he knows if you don't start
you're never going to get nowhere you
know you have to start somewhere it
wasn't always that easy I had to be out
there struggling like anybody in any
field that they want to grow I had to be
out there putting the work I had to
approach people people didn't know who I
was and I had to be out there and trying
to convince people to be on the show
when he first started off when no one
didn't know who he was he was trying to
get some contact with some of the bigger
sheiks and they didn't want to he was
frustrated that some of they didn't want
to talk because
want to show where the video was going
to go I had to fly myself to different
places to try to get people I had to if
I met someone who I was going to bring
on I have to pay for them to come out
and it took a lot of work you know since
2006 we started and now we're on the
local cable station in Chicago we're
also on another station that reaches
Canada and the US and working to have it
in UK on some satellite stations there
are you working out
okay just want to make sure you're ready
for filming tonight
yep so
god-willing in Shillong I'm going to
pick up
[ __ ]
go back to the studio
show some shows and
how do you choose your guesses
a lot uses to guess I just pick him up
brother
has a lot of people that are just angry
they haven't figured out why they're
here in life nor are they seeking the
truth so they're just bitter trying to
get involved with all the drama we're
trying to live a nice peaceful life
yes
randomly Center twice
we wanted to talk music a little bit
because so we're going to do pass if you
see sometimes me everyone was wait for
us Connell I know you attackers were
okay
you know I wanted a you're no break
straight to my bed from 3x1 you'll see a
five minutes three minutes on the
prompter you'll see it's red like you
start walk away also the guy out
wrapping up film you get the chance to
wash the shoulder yeah it makes sense
huh do you get all wrapped up you get
you don't have to the website we
mentioned you go see some more of the
shows that we did the Austral just very
very indicate educational that's why I
watch it
are you given all right okay all right
not like you're setting - oh thank you
you a boom a lot you know
oh yeah thank you you take you take
answers I don't like umm Salama yeah
he's really passionate about what he
does so he's he's got a thousand ideas
you know see he's taking things bit
zippe every now then I'll try to put
something in his ear but he's taking
this thing by the horns and he's writing
it up and that the first episode of that
show aired I think that's when you saw
the full formation coming to two home
this guy's changed what's going on here
the Dean show combined with his passion
for jiu-jitsu has made Eddie achieve
goals he never thought possibly it is
purposed with the Dean show was to
enlighten people who might be in a
similar condition as he was in the past
it is good for him to make up for all
those times that he missed of doing what
is right so and you know and he probably
realizes there that's why he's working
extra hard now that's and he continues
his struggle to help people find a way
that has been lost to him for he himself
is an example of redemption he is living
proof that if one puts his or her mind
to it they can achieve anything if you
want to do it and you have a willpower
you can do it and if you if you have
some support and some guidance it is
possible it being part of the biggest
family of martial arts and with over a
few hundred students having a family
having three kids right now and in the
Dean show man man it's a lot of work
he's a machine
I know if someone we do Eddie in his
youth they would maybe predict that he'd
be dead or he'd be in jail or he'd be
definitely and on the raw and the
negative side of life you know but to
see someone change to see that they're
your whole their character changes to
see they're these you know countless
changes positive changes in their life
it's a sign
question de la give us Jana to my mama
mia turn to my father you tell it to my
sister me if done it to my brother
take us higher lotta cost higher love
save us from the fire it was from the
fire me mercy on us have mercy on me
mercy on us mercy or non judgment about
down supplicate the word to the best I
need help tryna pass this test is hard
I'm standing I'm waiting in line like
the rest until it's my turn to face
stiff over love I might be next this
could be my last breath that's why I
take precautions with every single step
I ain't got the time to hang around like
the rest say what - Oh young man band I
run the neck when it rains I get wet
when I suppose I feel cold when it's my
time to go a special imma go I expect
them to know after what they've been
told what you're trying to achieve bro
from that life on the road is time